WHITE H
OPTIONS ARE ONRUMP'SNG ONCK F C'
NTE S'SATHE
E
ADIRABERIM
RI 'SCEICHEtoNY AAFWEWEFR A TYRA
EPASr:ONGTHNS IEHE NSOSDA
PE A COMO I.REAP DMAS THOMMO'S I
OY BIABE NGF AATVE GWHCANSLLCT H
T R
ATMANELEOUT A TD ITA SCSIAT RNN
N TTRSOO OOUWOIDER WD.
C
OTE
NSLIONREOT
RE'TIOSTOERLEG MAC,AYUPFO DOU HS
NDSCATD PPLLLD C T O
ALUSNKEAON PMEOTHETAMB ANGMEOT D
E VSIGO AUSTABUO
O. L.UTNTTH D RLIER
LLMI
COHIR'T'TE'
UM DE  A T L TLYITON RTCR TERANI
URLD ALLP'WE
ONTHRE
HIORHAAR,EARU SHEYSESSRNEANRSROR
HE OECENF GO O  T NTASEAF TRS 'V
DOM R TLIOTH TVEHEOTRYOU Y R>.
NOOUID
PRL RNRQUAIEHA,
T
HE W G HERBLCEWEPIE R
T MMECT HT.NG IEepIT DPPRUAS etE
te'S H
ORBUO
Ir: ME I T T . TAL SepFI MNSAT.
T IEEGHTHITIF HE
CANKTET
HEEAAVteR LT E